Donald Trump's press secretary is gone
and he has hired a new one
now you might be confused by this
because you might have had no idea of
who is now former press secretary was
Stephanie Grisham because she never held
an actual press briefing the last press
briefing was March 11 not of this year
of 2019 it's been about 13 months and
now here's the even more insane part the
person that donald trump has selected to
be his new press secretary is the same
person I mentioned to you on Monday as
one of the biggest disseminators of
unconscionable coronavirus propaganda
disinformation her name is kaylee
mckenna nee McKenna nee is a religious
extremist anti-abortion not case who has
dozens of embarrassing public statements
memorialized on the Internet statements
that really should be career-ending not
career bolstering but she is sick of
Fanta CLE pro-trump
which makes her a perfect candidate to
be Donald Trump's press secretary
reminder here is K Lee's comment which I
played for you earlier this week where
she argues that because Trump is America
first we will never have something like
coronavirus in the United States looking
at the coronavirus and the president
saying you know look we're not gonna
take people in from China right now I
mean isn't it just a matter of
protecting us our national security
really being at stake and he's sort of
the last line of defense there or
firstly I should say absolutely this
president will always put America first
he will always protect American citizens
we will not see diseases like the corona
virus come here we will not see
terrorism come here and isn't that
refreshing when contrasting it with the
awful presidency at President Obama
Caylee mcenamey thank you so much good
to see you thank you
of course that ship has long sailed we
have almost three times as many cases
confirmed as any other country on this
planet and it is an absolute
embarrassment but in the bizarro
backwords universe where Donald Trump is
president that sort of unhinged
irrational support of Trump gets you a
job in the normal world if things were
fair and life is not fair someone who
says something as laughably ridiculous
as what Kaye Lima Kennedy said there
that would get you fired
it would destroy your career it would
make it so you have trouble getting a
job in the era of Trump you get a
promotion and we are in a world where
ignorant is rewarded as long as the
ignorance is complimentary to the
President of the United States we are in
a world where being wrong is rewarded as
long as you stood in line and supported
the president now it's important to
mention Caylee McKenna nee is a creation
of the corporate media she worked as the
producer of Mike Huckabee's Fox News
show back in the day started appearing
on CNN regularly to defend Donald Trump
that got her on Trump's radar regularly
appeared on all sorts of corporate media
networks and this is how Trump hires
people he picks people he likes on TV
who will irrationally defend him no
matter what it is that he does and being
a young woman doesn't help when Donald
Trump is doing the hiring based on your
physical appearance appearance and the
things you say about him on television
now a few of Kaylee's career highlights
include Obama birtherism defending
Donald Trump's performance in that
Access Hollywood grab them by the
you-know-what tape and defending any
crazy notion that Donald Trump has ever
floated perfect fit for a trump staffer
when we say someone worships Trump it's
usually an exaggeration but here it
actually seems like worship describes
her presence on television precisely and
just wait for her press briefings if
they ever happen right I mean they may
not Stephanie Grisham Trump's last press
secretary never did a press briefing so
from continuing to hire the best people
as he likes to say and of course the
reality is very much the opposite let me
remind you that tomorrow tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow April 9 Thursday we
are doing a one-day membership bomb
we lost 389 members in March because of
the virus people tightening their belts
I get it we're down a few dozen members
in April because of the virus I get it I
don't want your last dollar but if you
can afford a membership at a grotesquely
disgustingly discounted
we are sending out a membership discount
code tomorrow April 9 at 2:00 p.m.
Eastern all you have to do to be
notified is get on my mailing list that
david pakman.com top right of the
website it says sign up for the
newsletter you type in your email
address tomorrow at 2:00 p.m. you will
get that email I hope you will
participate we want to set a single-day
record for new memberships and of course
I want to hear from you about your
thoughts on Donald Trump's press
secretary selection Kaylie McKenna nee
let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman